So, we need to build an app
that adapts well to all different devices.
But there's so many types of devices,
so where do we begin?
Well, we can start by grouping them
into buckets based on physical size.
We can have a bucket for phones,
and a bucket for 7-inch tablet's,
and a bucket for 10-inch tablet's as well.
You can go even more granular
based on screen width.
But these are the most common
buckets that you'll need.
Now, classifying based
on size alone is not enough.
Even among devices of the same size,
there's still a wide range
of screen densities.
Screen density is calculated
from the number of dots per inch
on the device or DPI.
The scale starts off with low density devices,
also known as LDPI devices.
It has about 120 dots per inch,
then it increases to medium denisty,
high density, all the way to
extra, extra, extra high density devices,
where the number
of dots per inch is much higher.
So, how do we build an app that accounts
for all these different screen densities?
Well, when we specify
layout dimensions,
we quickly realize
that we can't use pixels.
For example, a 48 pixel button
that looks fine on an MDPI device,
will look much smaller
on a higher density device
where the pixels are more compacted
and the physical size of 48 pixels
is much smaller.
The user wants a button
to be easily tappable,
so it shouldn't change
based on screen density.
So we need a consistent
unit of measure to define physical size,
and in Android we call that
density-independent pixels
or dips, or dp for short.
That way, a 48dp button will be
the same physical size
across all these different
screen densities.